bei uns ist jetzt der chef des
bundeswehrverbandes oberst andré wüstner
hier bei uns im studio energy bei uns
sind hallo jetzt sollen man hat sich
dazu entschlossen waffen an die ukraine
geliefert werden kann dass in dieser
situation überhaupt möglich sein wie
läuft so etwas ab so eine
waffenlieferung wie stellen wir sicher
dass diese waffen dort über banken ja
das ist eine schwierige operation man
muss teilweise fliegen es geht um
landtransport und natürlich darf man
diese routen vorher nicht offenlegen
aber es ist eine herausforderung der
aktuellen lage und man weiß ja auch all
das was jetzt noch folgt das wird
schlimmer werden ich bin bei ihnen auch
bei thema zurückhaltung was die
friedensverhandlungen anbelangt ich
glaube er putin versucht sich gerade
zeit zu verschaffen er führt neue kräfte
run der angriff ist ja zum stocken
gelangen und das wird die nächsten tage
bitterer werden was wir dort erleben und
deswegen kann nicht nachvollziehen dass
auch menschen sich jetzt gedanken machen
tief und andere städte zu verlassen
hoffe aber dass die ukraine weiterhin
tapfer bisher kämpfen denn damit hat
putin nicht gerechnet er hat
gleichermaßen nicht damit gerechnet dass
die nato das europa das die westliche
gemeinschaft zu geschlossen steht und
ich bin gespannt wie er weiter agiert
nur ist es ja wichtig dass diese waffen
ganz schnell ankommen und wir sehen dass
dort quasi im countdown abläuft so sehen
es zumindest die menschen in kiew ja
offenbar die rennen auf dem bahnsteig
die machen sich nicht nur gedanken wie
sie rauskommen sondern die nehmen ihre
beine in die hand die flüchten jetzt die
wollen noch in den zug rein drängen die
möglicherweise letzten züge das heißt
die waffen müssen schnell da sein geben
sie uns mit ihrer expertise eine
einschätzung wie schnell kann das gehen
das ist ja keine geringe menge das sind
1000 panzerfäuste das sind abwehrraketen
das schleppt man nicht so eben schnell
über die grenze darüber ich gehe davon
aus dass es heute wenn nicht schon
gestern begonnen hat und wenn es dann
darum geht die direkt an die front zu
bringen dann ist es natürlich eine frage
der einzel logistik wie man das macht
das werden teilweise keine
militärkonvois sein sondern die
hilfsfahrzeuge sprinter was auch immer
und sozusagen auch verdeckt verstecken
wie auch immer getarnt diese waffen nach
vorne zu bringen aber ich gebe ihnen
recht also abwarten dass nicht nur die
zweitbeste option diese bewaffnung muss
jetzt nach vorne und sie wird ja auch
genutzt wie man gerade erst wieder
gesehen haben
sagen sie ist seit gestern putin der
ganzen westlichen welt gedroht mit
seinen atomwaffen da stellen sich bei
mir ganz pragmatische fragen was hat
dieser mann genau wie weit kann das
reichen wie sehr ist deutschland davon
bedroht also auf der einen seite sage
ich es ist nichts neues denn in der
phase annexion der krim hatte ähnlich
agiert nichtsdestotrotz putin agiert
aktuell so irrational wie nie zuvor das
heißt wir wissen nicht handelt er nach
einem doktrin handbuch und wir können
sozusagen beurteilen was der nächste
schritt ist oder passieren nicht dinge
mit denen wir so eigentlich nicht
rechnen wollen wir wissen das atom u
boote ausgelaufen sind oder geradeaus
laufen im nordmeer mit mittelstrecken
und interkontinentalraketen wir wissen
er ist auch in der lage kleine
sprengsätze im bereich von städten oder
auch anderen regionen dieser welt zu
zünden deswegen ist wichtig dass der
nachrichtendienst in seinem verbund
international jetzt dran bleibt weil
noch mal das ist nicht ungefährlich auch
wenn ich keine angst machen will denn
angst und wurzeln ja nie gute ratgeber
aber muss die situation genau womit
dieser raketen nach den informationen
die wir haben sind die auf deutschland
ausgerichtet auf berlin beispielsweise
nein dafür dahingehend habe ich keine
kenntnisse aber der punkt ist der wir
wissen ja nicht nur stichwort
atom-u-boote putin hat ja an mehreren
ecken dieser welt bis hin nach syrien
solche waffen geliefert verteilt
disloziert wir wissen kaliningrad ist
ein standort wo er jederzeit
entsprechende raketen zünden kann mit
einem entsprechenden radius aber noch
ist es so dass wir nicht in dieser
eskalationsspirale sind mich wundert
dass so ein bisschen denn es ist ja auch
ein tick feige also konventionell kommt
er nicht weiter aber jetzt meint er
müsste schon abschrecken über eine
atomare variante oder diese mit ins
spiel bringen das ist zwar einerseits
ein politisches zeichen aber es erhöht
auch die präsenz dieses konflikts und
der nachhall fragt man sich natürlich wo
genau sind eigentlich unsere nato
atomraketen wo sind die überall
stationiert man spielt das natürlich
durch im kopf und denkt sich putin
konnte es mit so einer drohung wie denn
unsere reaktion wie würde das ablaufen
grundsätzlich ist es dann
eskalationsspirale auf beiden seiten da
kann und will ich jetzt gar nicht so
viel dazu sagen aber der punkt ist der
da gibt es pläne und skizzen ein motor
oder saniert sind ist das hochgeheime
weiß man dass wo sind die nato
atomwaffen in unserer nähe also ich weiß
einiges aber das kann ich hier nicht
sagen aha gut da können wir glaube ich
weiter nachfragen aber gut dass sie es
wissen und das ist sie gibt da kann man
sich das im zweifel letzte frage erst
gestern gab es eine wichtige
bundestagssitzung es gab eine 180 grad
wende in der deutschen politik es gab
einerseits darüber haben wir gesprochen
die zusicherung jetzt eben doch deutsche
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und
gleichzeitig 100 milliarden euro für sie
für die bundeswehr in den nächsten
jahren nachdem all dem was sie in den
vergangenen jahren unterfinanzierung und
ewig lange rüstungsprojekte erlebt haben
bei der bundeswehr gehen sie überhaupt
davon aus dass sie noch was davon haben
von den 100 milliarden euro gehe ich
davon aus gestern definitiv das war
irgendwie ein historischer tag in
jeglicher hinsicht mit blick auf das was
passiert ist im parlament standing
ovations auch in richtung botschaft
botschafter aus der ukraine aber
überhaupt die gesamt haltung die es
einmal neuausrichtung der
außenpolitischen achse deutschlands da
ist ja etwas passiert ich weiß gar nicht
wie man das beschreiben soll aber auch
in historisch mit blick auf die
bundeswehr weil diese unsere politik
dieses parlament endlich erkannt hat
sicherheit geht nicht für 0 frieden muss
verteidigt werden und das heißt eben
auch das nicht nicht nur sagen kann
innere und äußere sicherheit sind kern
staatlichen handelns unterfüttern und
jetzt ist eine aufgabe der
verteidigungsministerin daraus etwas zu
machen denn viel geld muss nicht
unbedingt richtig eingesetzt werden und
das ist jetzt so das gebot der stunde
jetzt zu unterfüttern bei munition bei
schutzwesten bei bewaffnungen bei
fahrzeugen etc um nicht nur blick auf
diesen aktuellen konflikt in der ukraine
uns fit zu machen sondern insbesondere
für die situation wenn wir vielleicht
einen neuen us-präsident haben der sagt
ihr europäer kümmert euch jetzt mal
selbst dann endlich europäisch fit zu
sein und eine gute
sicherheitsarchitektur zusätzlich ein
danke herr oberst danke an
bundeswehrverbandes andré wüstner danke
dann geben so